when we first learned about glycolysis
we saw that if you start with a molecule
of glucose and you carry forward with
glycolysis that glucose which is a six
carbon sugar it's got oxygens and
hydrogens as well but it's a six carbon
sugar it gets split into two pyruvate
molecules and each pyruvate has three
carbons and in the process of doing so
we're able to produce a net of two atps
we use two atps in the investment phase
then we produce four atps in the payoff
phase for a net
of two atps but that's not all that
happens you also have two nad molecules
nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
getting reduced to nadh and why is it
getting reduced well we see it's a
positive it's a positive molecule here
it becomes a neutral molecule it gains
electrons so this over here becomes
becomes reduced now the next question
you might have is well what happens next
well if you're
me or you you might continue on and if
if you have enough oxygen you'll
continue on with cellular respiration
things move on to the mitochondria
because the pyruvates and the nadhs can
be can also be used to produce more atp
the pyruvate gets more broken down in
the krebs cycle also known as the citric
acid cycle and also and that produces
atps and nadhs and the nadhs can
participate in the electron transport
chain which eventually leads to even
more atps being produced but what if
you're in a situation that maybe we
don't have oxygen or maybe you're just
like you're just the type of
type of organism that doesn't like to
use oxygen or or doesn't know how to use
oxygen what happens next
well what we're going to talk about in
this video is one potential pathway and
that's lactic acid fermentation
which is one of the two major forms of
fermentation lactic
acid
fermentation
for
men
lactic acid fermentation and lactic acid
fermentation isn't so much about
producing more atps it's more about
recycling the pyruvate and the nadh even
though the pyruvate and nadh can
it has free energy to give that could be
converted to atp if we're going to be
doing lactic acid fermentation we kind
of give up give up on that and then we
actually use the pyruvate to oxidize the
nadh to become nad plus so that we have
more nad plus for glycolysis to occur
again so organisms that do that do
fermentation their main energy source is
the glycolysis and then the fermentation
is all about recycling what it views as
waste materials pyruvate and nadh so
that you can have more nad to have
glycolysis occurring again
now we you might say oh is this just
some strange thing that we don't
encounter much in life but
probably every day or maybe at least
every week you probably consume some
organisms that perform lactic acid
fermentation this right over here this
is a picture of yogurt yogurt is what we
get when you have the when you have
species of lactobacillus digesting the
sugars in the milk and then they're
performing glycolysis and then they
perform lactic acid fermentation
converting the pyruvate into lactate or
if it has if you if you view the
conjugate acid version of it
lactic acid you could say pyruvic acid
lactic acid pyruvate
is the conjugate base for pyruvic acid
lactate is the conjugate base for lactic
acid but that's what's giving it that's
what's giving it its uniquely yogurt
taste it's it's this it's this bacteria
here
the lactobacillus this is this is just
one variation of it and there's slightly
different variations of lactobacillus
that do each of these foods but this is
yogurt this right over here if you're
into korean food this is kimchi this
uses a variation of lactobacillus to
once again perform lactic acid
fermentation on the sugars in the
vegetables this is sauerkraut once again
a variation of lactobacillus a species
of lactobacillus performing lactic
lactic acid fermentation on the sugars
in the cabbage sauerkraut literally
means sour cabbage and that's that's
what it is and so let's think a little
bit more about what's going on
so as i mentioned it's all about taking
your taking your pyruvate or your
pyruvic acid the way i've drawn it right
over here this is pyruvic acid
pi
ruvic
pyruvic acid
right over here because we have our
hydrogen proton if we lose our hydrogen
proton this is the same thing drawn
again but now we don't have the hydrogen
proton here this oxygen kept that
electron and all of the other hydrogens
all the hydrogens here there they are
implicit so the three hydrogens here
they're implicit on this carbon i've
just drawn it with a different notation
and so this one where we've lost the
proton we would call this pyruvate
pi
by
roov8 and what we have happening is the
pyruvic acid or the pyruvate is used to
oxidize the nadh take away a hydride
take away an electron from
well actually more than just electron
but
net net you have the nadh losing
electrons and so if it's losing
electrons it's getting oxidized so it's
oxidized
so that the nad plus can be reused in
glycolysis and when pyruvic acid does
this to the nadh it gets it gets reduced
it gets reduced
it gets reduced it gains electrons and
if we're thinking about the acid forms
it would turn into this right over here
is lactic acid
lactic
lactic
lactic acid and that's why we call it
lactic acid fermentation because you're
taking that pyruvate if you had oxygen
around if you knew how to do it use the
oxygen you might continue on with
cellular respiration and use that for
energy but lactic acid fermentation we
use it to oxidize the na nadh so we get
more nad plus
and let's just now get a better
appreciation for all of this happens so
the first thing that i want to show you
because a lot of times in biology
classes you just learn nad nadh and it
just seems like this somewhat abstract
molecule but this is a picture of it
this is nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide and it's kind of a mouthful
but when you break it down you see these
patterns that you see repeatedly in
biology this is this right over here
this is the this one is what gives us
the nicotinamide this right over here is
our good friend adenine we see that in
atp we see that also as one of the
nitrogenous bases in dna and rna you
have ribose right over here so it's
derived from ribose you have a phosphate
group you have a phosphate group so
nicotinamide adenine you have a
nucleotide right over there you have
another nucleotide right over there so
it's nicotine adenine
dinucleotide so the name makes a lot of
sense but i wanted to show this to you
to get an appreciation that it's a it's
a fairly it's not a you know it's it's a
it's a fairly involved molecule over
here you know sometimes when you just
see the letters nad you don't get a full
appreciation for it and it's a it's a
coenzyme and we learned about coenzymes
in other videos where the the enzyme
that catalyzes this is lactic acid
dehydrogenase and remember enzymes
enzymes for the most part just these big
you know
protein structures so all folded up in
all different different ways
and then you have the nad
the nad
or the case in the case of lactic acid
fermentation right over here you have
the nadh
so this is the nadh right over here and
i'm i'm just kind of drawing what it
could look like this isn't actually what
it looks like
it's going to react it's going to react
with the pyruvate and let me do that in
a
it's going to
react with the pyruvate and by doing so
even though the pyruvate you might
formally consider to be the substrate of
the enzyme the whole purpose is to get
your nadh to be oxidized to lose a
hydrogen and an extra electron so a
hydrogen proton a hydrogen electron and
another electron so really lose a
hydride so how does that happen
well it happens
because you have this nitrogen here it
has an extra lone pair of electrons
so it can form that lone pair can form a
double bond right over there well if
that carbon if if this now has a double
bond this carbon has to let go of this
double bond so that goes over there
that goes
over
over there and then if there's now a
double bond over here which we see in
the end product this carbon is going to
have to let go of a bond and it lets go
of the entire covalent bond with this
hydrogen so both of the electrons so
it's going to let go
of both of these electrons
right over here and then both of those
electrons can attach
can attach to this carbon right over
there now that carbon gets forms a new
covalent bond it has to let go of one of
its covalent bonds and so it could let
go it could let go of one of these
double bonds with this oxygen and those
could either go back to that oxygen or
more likely they can be used to grab a
hydrogen proton maybe from a passing
water molecule or hydronium molecule and
so
i could draw it like this
could grab a hydrogen
a hydrogen proton and so what do we end
up with
well this
that lone pair of electrons is now there
this
we now have a double bond right over
there now we've lost one of these
hydrogens i obviously haven't drawn all
of the hydrogens in these molecules so
now we have
now we are back to nad and since this
this this nitrogen has essentially it
was neutral before but now it is it is
instead of keeping these two electrons
it's sharing these two electrons so now
it's going to have a positive charge so
this is why we call it nad
nad plus it lost a hydrogen
and an electron a hydrogen the
hydrogen's electron and another electron
so now it has a positive it now has a
positive charge and the pyruvate the
pyruvate is now the conjugate well the
way i've drawn it here since we've i
show it deprotonated i would say that
this is now lactate
this is now lactate if we had our proton
over here we would call it we would call
it lactic acid so anyway hopefully you
you get a kick out of this i i know i do
it's it's kind of interesting that all
of this can happen i mean lactobacillus
isn't the only isn't the only organism
that does this but this is a fairly
useful organism for all sorts of all
sorts of delicious food that we have
and just get appreciation you know i'm
always my mind's always blown that these
fairly complex processes are constantly
occurring in nature all around us
sometimes even in our own bodies and
these organisms that we would consider
quite quite small for example this
lactobacillus right over here this is on
the order of this is on the order of 5
to 10 micrometers 5 micrometers so 5
millionths 5 millionths of a meter